dopo soli tre episodi da fondo iniziata
la serie è successo l'incredibile
ragazzi vi lascio al video
non vi dico nient'altro in due delle
zona comunque secondo me potevano
scendere anche senza pur facendo
malissimo però c'è il sesto posto qua
una betoniera delle stallo o c'è una
guardia vieni capri questa free questa
la prima prima ora quando vai perché
sono mafioso allora basta esiste il buio
pesto c'è il buio pomodoro no ciccio che
no ciccio acceso negli scritti che devo
preservare la mia curiosa l'amico sono
comunque la domanda è se non riuscissimo
a tornare indietro come facciamo trova
una torcia la trovo io devo trovare una
torcia eccola qua accesa pure precarica
eccoli qua dove stiamo andando
esattamente 6 da tre 3 3 r
ok adesso ci aiutasse che non vede nulla
gli inquilini quadri qua io se fossi in
prigione di stesse scappando farei di
poteri dei scoraggino fammi sentire per
i consumi nasconderei esatte per fare
bene per quello di resti di nuovo in
galera ma poi sappiamo tornano indietro
sul ventre fonte molto si è fatto ormai
siamo possiamo fare schiena schiena
amore si sicuro famose che mi hai visto
lo sapevo mi manca la mentalità da
escapista non so se si dice così però
perché se la carica piazza scafi assurda
scafista che
[Musica]
sì avevo visto fare il music time allora
ciccio state dobbiamo fuggire di
prigione
tu non sei la persona adeguata vai
perfetto neanche io mi va il coro contro
ruota verso destra dai esatto ok
nessuna scusa scusate mi portano importa
ok ok
mamma mia che dice grandi mamma mia
mamma mi ha preso un break ai fenomeni
i fenomeni poi capito perché no allora
in quasi lavorate a livelli di solito ci
avranno male agli addominali ma siamo
soprattutto le sedi dell'ikea giocare
che premendo un tasto loro si stanno
spaccando la schiena bene che uomini che
ho mi allora buon senso funione sea che
deteneva in agli ufo chi si riesce ad
avere la chiave inglese peso un buon
pressing e tento workshop
qui dobbiamo ritornare tutti indietro no
vabbè maga che casino che devono fare
che si fatti che poteva dare la chiave
inglese
la chiave inglese
eh si meno male che ci hanno trasportati
se non ci faremo fare tutte le vie i
cunicoli però va versato diverte a beh
se poi questi dunque vanno prendono una
roba poi la prossima volta
oggi serve una macchina per scappare è
quella la troviamo solo dal carro
attrezzi e lo trovo che una portata
macchina di sotto porta l'arte nasce da
ora che la vista da dove dove non sono
previste questo caso che sono coesa che
si cambia mi sembra molto figo ma che
bravo che sono poi c'è un lavoro vero
finalmente amiche ma c'è metal detector
poiché dobbiamo passarlo tra le sbarre
aspetto dovremmo di strada ne guardi
accesa cerci 04 possiamo usare st grata
come hai visto cosa se non usare quella
per passare l'oggetto la grafica è
l'unica amica ha infatti colloqui
periodo trovarla e dove trovare la
chianina eccola qualche inglese cosa te
ne fai te la infili cosa se ne fa questo
anche all'inglese ma devo distrarre il
titolo è in qualche modo
ciao ti abbiamo visto stavo parlando
tranquilli o faremo work fermo ecco
esatto prova bravissimo vero che
vogliono più ne ha chiesto sì li ho
appena chiesto potessi prestarmelo di
uno guarda leggo le varie si
incasserebbero va bene grazie
all'avanzato ciao
e stato bellissimo ma tu stai lì e io
vada da parte della grata e provincia ma
sembra una grata la rotta
perfetto perfetto bene perche e cosi
adesso vedo se riesco uscire bella sega
nella sega capisco portare la cellula
chiamate io lo portavamo nella cella per
fare bordello mi sa che mi sarebbero
aiuto qua perché sicuramente a deve
perquisirmi occhio dammi la mano
ecco faccio come nick ho capito come
fare tu perquisiti vari esatto ma entra
poi acquisisci il noto gioco poi
avvicinati alla finestra
lei perfetto ct lascia incoerenti è
stato semplicissimo ma inviato verso l
pub venia celava in acea lobby l'appunto
manca per lecce niente siamo arrivati
semi di co.co.co porca vacca queste
brutte che si parla ciao amici se provo
la mission è stato semplice
no sarà addirittura correndo va bene la
banca mart aspetta che arrivata poi
aspetta aspetta che arriva arriva rigori
resisti un secondo un secondo porto che
a vacca e mi sa che me la dovrei passare
in qualche modo sicuro e che c'è di
commenta la cherry commentato ci sta
aiutando vieni passa alla pasta una
bravo grande grandissima
non so dove nasconda le giornaliste di
processo ammessa di processo già dietro
perfetto mai così number one
mi piace così enrico mentana
dimmi quello che vuoi e così la fanno
più invece di toccarmi siamo stati bravi
in c a grandine si è tenuto bravissimi
siamo per scappare ciccio si carico per
questa cosa carichissimo suonava la
campanella uscito a scuola c'è che bello
quei bei ricordi
poi era uguale come scappare i principi
canto quello sempre cosa siamo già lì
siamo cioè per chi rimane che non ci
siamo fatti di tutto il tempo con che
noi a lance stancev italia è quella dei
rappresentanti e avvocato gioco che la
donna
[Musica]
promosso tranquilli devo dire tanto c'è
un temporaneo lo senti bene la tempesta
prodotti ma perché sai il sangue freddo
e ciò che dobbiamo avere sempre quindi
tutte le situazioni loro fanno bene sono
tranquillo per fai finta di stare
facendo la cosa giusta una partita a
briscola è fatto che ad umido ma le luci
rosse sì ma dove l'uscita da fermo
dissenso by cisco
stiamo lavorando bene il browser cd
fantastica storia venica venica venica
dovremo salire qualche party tipo qua
guarda lo aveva già la roba già da
strumenti di burro ma mai sospingerli
smetti spinge cavo tesco vieni vieni che
dobbiamo scappare come dei topi tasca ma
esattamente dove che siamo c'è perché se
non hanno una mappa della prigione come
fanno a sapere da letto sono due guardie
che parlano attenzione se ci beccano poi
ci facciamo l'ergastolo
ap di premere per ripararsi dietro a uno
deve distrarli sicura e l'altra sera non
so come back to black compiti strangers
un po e non sicuramente sì qualcosa qui
vediamo se riesco a fare qualcosa di
decente in chiaro la v ok mi sono messo
mamma mia
piove ma ti pare che regola mini qua
ok no ma ci sentono 105 ma si sentono
belle forme scemo subito proprio
recapito sanno quando c'è il tuono a noi
dobbiamo saper notti che bravo
bravissimo mai stati troppo siamo sul
tetto e questa tesi ci fai o ma guarda
lì per questa gente da raimondo adesso
faremo ma quello che va bene ci credo
metti che pure ko ma come aspetta che ci
provo vado andato andato madonna io ho
fatto svenire della tonalità te in
faccia non so come ho fatto questo e
l'ufficio del direttore con la sigla poi
fare le cose un po più spacchi vetri
così va bene può permesso di vieni qua
vito basta guardare certe sua stella
c'è qualcuno nell'ascensore occhio
dobbiamo scendere immagino possa dire
roberts dicendosi d'accordo sono e
scendere nel salire rimango qua a
braccia pienza vacanza viene liquidata
ok poi saputo guai po attorno al ruggi
la torre perché vieni occhi alla luce
occhi all'oggetto bravissimo
c'è sta ritornando forse tornando ai ora
poi subito sotto e ciccio subito subito
subito gravissimo lo pop bravo qua siamo
vicini quindi inter ieri è abbastanza it
e qui siamo percorrere
l'abbiamo fatto adesso salgo io aspetta
volevo stordire immagini che poi ci
metti capace di giocare ad un gas perché
vuoi un bello e sta luce aero through ok
ora che sta a girare questa luce che
punto io a casa e aspetta però mai pazzo
e sospetti simosi registrato infatti non
dovremmo segnatamente sua idea è che la
trovo io dentro vieni qua ho capito se
va beh come appendiabiti voi fa sta roba
poi ci riesco a fare 1 sapendo e muore
dopo un secolo si segue a me ora ecco
[Musica]
sei fuori semplifica spero di riuscire a
farlo anch'io
c'è con una gruccia capito che è come
che fortuna totale ma figurati sono mi
succederà una rosa del kitsch a tienimi
tanto peso poco orca che ci sono
d'accordo sono accorti che i primi premi
schiacce schiacciati questo prendo solo
rimane bray perché non mi va dai ciccio
dei schiacciano il tasto maledetto
schiaccia lo schiaccio tra si affacciano
su questa parte da cannes hanno una mila
da cani ci hanno sparato siamo in casa
dai vai quadri ma solo fa che è male
corri corri codici giocò li caricherei
aiuto ai paesi di qua vai vai se ti esu
da scorrano ciccio già fuori
siamo poi siamo usciti ai rigori quindi
lega suoli ce l'abbiamo fatta ma non è
detto perché dobbiamo anche fuggi se ci
ripigliano dopo un minuto non è servito
a niente quindi scoprirete come va a
finire le prossime piste cose semplici
ragazzi come dice come si sa solo che si
stiano ci vediamo al prossimo vita
[Musica]